[Music]
don't be a scrooge this holiday season
no bah humbugs this is all about
kindness and that's where we begin this
hour with our kindness 101 series with
Steve Hartman in it we share stories
built around kindness and character and
the people who have mastered those
qualities today's lesson is gratitude in
honor of Thanksgiving Steve and his kids
introduce us to someone who has always
been grateful even when he didn't seem
to have much to be grateful for
good morning and welcome to kindness
101. this of course is my daughter Meryl
hi everyone today's class is about
gratitude for definition we go live to
my brother Emmett at the dictionary desk
Emmett gratitude is a strong feeling of
appreciation or thankfulness for someone
or something you know you guys are
always grateful to your mom and me
whenever we take you on vacation or buy
you a gift or something but it's
interesting you've never once showed
your appreciation for the bathroom sink
but I have once no you've never thanked
me for the sink if I'm
if I'm around the house and say I'm
thankful for this carpet and that table
might take a while you don't have enough
time to joke gratitude for everything in
the world yeah being grateful for the
things we take for granted is hard for
everyone fortunately I have a story to
help with that this is a recent addition
to our archive but destined to become a
lifelong teaching tool for finding
gratitude
what may look like a house to you is
something much more magnificent to the
boy inside what did you think when you
saw this place for the first time who
said it's second heaven second heaven
yes you pass through this before you go
to the big event that is what I believe
so
he means that literally and why wouldn't
he Abraham and his brother James are
from Sierra Leone they were homeless
before finding their way to an orphanage
and eventually to their new family
outside Charlotte North Carolina Joe and
Jamie Walker adopted them last year and
they say the boys have been wide-eyed
with Wonder ever since every little
thing that we take for granted I hit the
button to open our front gate
everything is Magic to them it's magic
whether it's a present just showing up
on Christmas morning
or something mundane like a car wash the
kids are constantly Blown Away
but the biggest surprise came on
Abraham's birthday you had birthdays
before you came here how did you
celebrate them
that would be a crazy question why is
that a crazy question I never celebrate
them I never know it was my birthday
happy birthday
so when the song started and his mom
appeared with that glowing tribute
Abraham was overwhelmed
when I see the cake I thought that is
the most beautifulest thing I've ever
seen the birthday cake
it's not just a birthday cake
it's a blessing a cake
a blessing cake and what a blessing it
is that once a year friends and family
gather just to honor our existence most
of us take that for granted but not in
this house not anymore
just being reminded that we need to stop
and be super grateful for what we do
have
a good wish for America from this
American dream come true
the boy who single-handedly renamed the
birthday cake joins us now hello Abraham
hello sir when you blew out your candles
did you make a wish
it's good to keep my family alive and
protect them and child them with more
happiness in their lives
uh do you have any idea for people who
look around their lives and can't seem
to find much if anything can be to go
for there's always something to be
grateful for
even the moment that you're alive you
need to be grateful for that so even
when you're homeless one of the poorest
people on the planet you still found
reason to be thankful yes but it
wouldn't seem to us like you would have
anything to be thankful for the one
thing that I was so thankful for is I
never get seed you never got sick so you
were thankful for your health even when
you were homeless yep
a lot of people in this country across
the political Spectrum think that this
country is going in the wrong direction
what are they missing
gratitude
I appreciating what you have now you
always need to give stents in each and
every second whatever you were doing
well Abraham thank you very much for the
perspective that you've given to all
Americans and and of course we're very
grateful that you joined us thank you
bye you know for most of us because we
do take so much for granted gratitude
has to be a conscious effort so here's a
suggestion this is something that we've
done in our family at the beginning of
the day take 10 pennies and put them in
your left pocket then spend the day
actually looking for things that you're
grateful for once you find one move one
penny from your left pocket into your
right pocket and we guarantee at the end
of the day you'll have a lot more than a
dime
thanks for watching and don't forget to
stay kind
apartment family that last line was just
a gym
wow but I love the 10 Penny thing and we
used to have a gratitude Journal where
you write down everything then you got
tired of writing stuff down because you
start taking it for granted Abraham is
such a good reminder May we all may he
and his brother have many many more
birthdays I love that story yeah that's
an example of how you just be present
right because it's all about perspective
we aren't trying times and there are
some things that make us sad and bring
us down but there are so many things to
be grateful for I love that story I love
our family and love that house beautiful
kitchen beautiful house beautiful
kitchen I love it room for one more Gail
at all